newly released nine one one calls reveal
LeSean McCoy is former girlfriend told
police she suspected the NFL star was
involved in her beating
delecia Accord own called police moments
after she was pistol-whipped by a masked
assailant Tuesday mark Strassmann is
outside the suburban Atlanta home where
she was attacked mark good morning good
morning Buffalo Bill Starr LeSean McCoy
owns this house behind me and against
his wishes Delicia Cardone kept living
here even after their relationship ended
her lawyer says she's recovering from
her injuries but scared her attackers
still all of us the attack around 3:00
a.m. Tuesday left delecia accord Owens
face battered and bloodied and her arm
bruised Corden said she was attacked by
a short black man wearing a mask and all
black clothing she also implicated her
former boyfriend Buffalo Bills running
back
LeSean McCoy officers have been to the
house three other times in the past year
last July
McCoy called police because Cardone
allegedly refused to give him back
high-end jewelry items loaned to him by
jewelers he was also worried Corden
might make false accusations about him
crazy Corden's lawyer told CBS this
morning the jewelry pieces were birthday
presents for McCoy Tanya Mitchell Graham
also says her client is no longer
certain the NFL star was involved in the
attack the NFL has been criticized over
its handling of domestic abuse
allegations against players in the past
McCoy has not been charged and denies
any involvement
AJ Perez is an investigative reporter at
USA TODAY's force the NFL investigators
will will try to get as much information
as they can from the police until
someone's arrested there's really
nothing that they thought I can do at
this point
local police have not said whether McCoy
is cooperating with them they have made
no arrests and at this point the
investigation is ongoing
also McCoy says he has had nothing to do
with it his ex-girlfriend according to
her lawyer is now planning to move out
of this house Alix mark thank you